so he spoke last night at the University
of Utah if you run down we have some
pretty amazing information from there
plus Hugh Hefner is dead and aside from
talking First Amendment boobs will also
talk about tax reform and where that is
give you all of the information I'm Ben
Shapiro this is Ben Shapiro show okay so
I want to start by talking about Hugh
Hefner because you have to his death is
apparently a deep cultural moment you
know the obituaries are just endless the
New York Times ran a 3300 word obituary
about a guy who's mostly famous for
putting boobs in magazine which is
pretty incredible live the life of an a
Saudi oil Sheik but occasionally
published John Updike and Norman Mailer
and therefore I guess his entire life
was just roses and nothing but we'll get
to all of that and as you may have
noticed I don't abide by this rule that
when someone dies we have to pretend
they were awesome so I'm gonna talk
about the good the bad and the ugly and
what Hugh Hefner meant to culture and
what we should take away from that but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at wink so does the
current news cycle make you want to
drink heavily if so I think it's the
place to go their wine is just terrific
people around the office I haven't tried
their mind they say that it's just
wonderful but what makes wink special if
you don't know anything about wine if
you're an ignoramus like I am and you
don't know what you're drinking
turpentine or wine or Manischewitz
doesn't really matter to you but you
have to go to a dinner party don't look
like a fool you go tooling they have an
algorithm and you tell them what you're
about to eat what your tastes are and
they'll recommend the best bottle of
wine and they will send it directly to
you so now you know and you don't look
foolish and the wine is terrific so go
over and check it out right now
wink is offering listeners $20 off your
first order when you go to try wink calm
at /femme it's try wink calms flashman
it's about winc calm and again you take
that brief palate profile quiz and
they'll recommend distinct interesting
lines customized to your palate to be
shipped directly to your door every
month and right now wink is offering
listeners 20 bucks off your first order
when you go to try wink calm slash then
go and check it out
it is awesome everybody at the office
uses it and they say that if the wine is
just terrific okay so I was going to
begin with Trump anomic but it's more
fun to talk about Hugh Hefner you're
right I mean this is why Hugh Hefner is
a cultural figure because we have to
pretend that Hugh Hefner was a
forward-thinking
of the culture instead of basically a
purveyor of pornography now none of this
is to say that he doesn't have a First
Amendment right to push his pornography
I mean he did have a First Amendment
right to push his pornography although I
think there actually is a fairly decent
argument under the First Amendment that
the First Amendment was not supposed to
cover up Senate II like I don't think
that John Adams and James Madison were
sitting around in 1789 thinking to
themselves you know what we really need
to protect Hugh Hefner with the money
shot
that's what we need to protect right but
Robert Bork argues in his book talking
about the First Amendment is that the
First Amendment was essentially in
trying to protect political speech that
was the goal but let's assume that we're
going to take a libertarian position on
the First Amendment better the
government should not regulate any of
this that make government should
regulate the wrong stuff so let's say
that all the stuff is protected now the
question becomes was Hugh Hefner's
business good for the world or was it
kind of bad for the world so what I've
seen a lot of in the obits today is
focus on stuff that is not Hugh Hefner's
core business right it's in a lot of
focus on the fact that you supported
civil rights which is right terrific you
know who else supported civil rights
Rosa Parks you know what she didn't do
pose nude right so this idea that Hugh
Hefner is somehow culturally important
because of civil rights is not the case
okay let's be real about this you have
Gray's famous because he was an old perv
okay you use a perv from the time that
he was young and he's a perv when he was
super old and become a parody of himself
he didn't become a different human
he wasn't different at 30 than he was at
91 he's the exact same person he never
changed and that's why it was so
ridiculous watching him try to live the
life of a 30 year old swinging bachelor
when he was 91 and somebody added milk
is prostate for him the whole thing is
ridiculous so the New York Times runs
this glowing öbut of Hugh Hefner
I didn't look it up I was I was trying
to figure out whether they granted more
time to Hugh Hefner Ronald Reagan they
did grab more time to Ronald Reagan so
good for the New York Times on that they
granted more times if you happen to than
William F Buckley
which i think is sort of telling about
where the Times stands on this but
here's what they write and this is I
don't have to give you indicators like
this I'll just read you this glowing
profile if you have not only one of the
greatest human beings to have ever
walked the earth because Moses Jesus you
have nur so here is Hugh Hefner Hugh
Hefner who created Playboy magazine and
spun it into a media and entertainment
industry giant all the while as it's
very public avatar squiring attractive
young women and sometimes marrying them
well into his eighties
died on Wednesday at his home the
Playboy Mansion
in Los Angeles he was 91 hey what's
imagine for a second that Donald Trump
god forbid
had died before he became president of
the United States his obituary would
read very much like this from the near
times right Donald Trump man famous for
swearing around young women and
sometimes marrying them but now the New
York Times doesn't like Donald Trump
because Donald Trump's a political
figure right on the on the right and
therefore he's an evil by oh man with
women evil and vile understand now I
think that Hugh Hefner was pretty vile
with women I think that trumps history
is not particularly great with women
I'm pretty consistent on this stuff but
it is amazing how the politics shift how
people view people's treatment of women
I was enough to remember when feminists
thought Hugh Hefner was gross but now
he's sort of a hero right Hugh Hefner is
great he liberated us from the
constraint of our own sexual Puritanism
first of all the arrogance in self
aggrandizement on the 1960s generation
feeling that they are the first to
discover that it feels good when you put
a penis in a vagina it's just incredible
to me like I'm sorry people have known
this since forever this is how evolution
built humans and animals like there's
nothing new here and treating it as
though there was some sort of grand
movement forward because you have her
put boobs that men like in magazines and
then slapped John Updike article between
the boobs like this was the this is
always the joke about Playboy right he'd
put these kind of highfalutin essays in
the middle of money shots with 18 year
old girls and that was like ooh isn't he
a sophisticate isn't he a sophisticate
now wouldn't he have been more of a
sophisticated he just I don't know
published John Updike like maybe the
only way he thought he could get people
to read Updike was to put it between the
boobs but I'm pretty sure that the main
the main point of Playboy was the boobs
and not the John Updike and he was just
trying to facilitate his own fame and
reputation for being a sophisticate by
publishing
highfalutin essays there's no difference
in Playboy and hustler magazine except
for the essays and this this bizarre
cultural impression that Hugh Hefner was
somehow a force for a tremendous good
while Larry Flynt is just a smut
purveyor anyway here is what the New
York Times continues to write you know
before I got there I want to say that
it's you want to watch how America is
evolved
don't look at Hector look at the
feminists take on after so the feminists
take on Hefner in the in the 1960s was
that Hefner was somebody who is helping
to objectify women which was 100
true and then the feminist state became
he's in power in limine he's given women
the opportunity to do what exactly
disrobe in front of men if they see fit
and this is empowering okay like women
always had that power because men have
lizard brain and we like naked women I
mean like I understand why it's like a
very difficult concept and then it
turned into no he's a cultural hero
because he empowered women okay oh my
really if you think that it is
empowering to women to publish nude
photos of them maybe the woman wants it
but as a general that's the maybe
empowering to that individual woman in
that sense I suppose but is it
empowering to women all over the United
States that men are looking at lots of
pictures of naked women if you think
that's the case I would recommend you
talk to a man one time like this many
times and if you do you will recognize
that men watch pornography are not on
the side typically of being more
empowered toward women and that's just
not the way that this works men who have
respect for women don't tend to rebel in
pornography
yeah because again there is something at
odds of seeing something as human beings
seeing someone as an actual object
worthy of genuine affection love and
respect anyway in the endless obituary
continues Hefner the man and the playboy
the brand were inseparable
both advertise themselves as emblems of
the sexual revolution an escape from
American priggishness and wide our
social intolerance both were derided
over the years as vulgar as adolescents
as exploitative and finally is
anachronistic all of those criticisms
are true but mr. Hefner was a stunning
success success from the moment he
emerge from the early 1950s his timing
was perfect
don't you understand he was slapping
those Puritans right in the face I note
about those sexual appearance into the
1940s they had more babies than any
generation in American history
they knew what sex was again again every
generation seems to think that they're
the only people have ever discovered
sexual organs and it's just incredible
today from people who are my age right
people who are younger well my parents
didn't know anything about sex but I
know something about sex guess what your
parents do you know well said their
parents you know how I know this because
you're here because he was
compared to Jay Gatsby Citizen Kane and
Walt Disney but mister Hepburn was his
own production he repeatedly like in his
led to a romantic movie and start an
ageless sophisticated silk pajamas
and smoking jacket hosting a
never-ending party for famous and
fascinating people well doesn't mean you
have to like in his life to a romantic
movie right he was a rich guy who got a
bunch of women to disrobe in front of
him who didn't have any affection for
him and who are occupy man do you really
think all these hot young 21 year olds
we're like that hot on the 80 year olds
creepy right he couldn't even sell his
house because he insisted that he be
allowed to live in the house and nobody
wanted to live in the house with him he
tried to sell his house in LA like a
couple of years ago and no one was
willing to buy it one of his
preconditions is that he would be still
wandering around the house and nobody
wanted that guy wandering around the
house in his bathrobe plus I mean what
would it do to that home price again des
if he backlight into place my goodness
this is the first issue of Playboy was
published in 1953 when mr. Hefner was 27
a new father married to buy his accounts
the first woman he had slept with and I
love this I'm gonna skip forward a
little bit here because the what he says
about his wife is really quite
incredible about his his first wife he
says still mr. Hefner wielded fierce
resentment against his ear as sexual
strictures which he said had choked off
his own youth a virgin until he was 22
he married his longtime girlfriend dong
dong dong dong horror of Horrors he was
a virgin until he was married yeah
that's what made his life empty and
meaningless
it wasn't the endless sex with a random
bevy of women and the uselessness of his
own and the uselessness of his own
perspective no it was it really will
really ruin him is that he didn't have
sex until he was 22 I'm sure that that
ruined his life just as it made
meaningless lives at Thomas Aquinas just
as it made meaningless the life of Jesus
right all of these lives were
meaningless if they'd had sex at 15
guess how much you know what they could
have done you know what Thomas Aquinas
would have thought if that's what he had
an orgasm at age 16 can you just imagine
me it's so stupid I was married at 23 I
was a virgin until I was married it was
a good decision you know why because the
only person I have ever had sex with is
my wife we're gonna be married for 10
years I promise you my life is
significantly more fulfilling then Hugh
Hefner's what he's I'm not gonna die
lonely and alone as Napa said he lived
as he died Nevada I'm not gonna die
lonely and alone surrounded by people
who don't know me and don't really care
about me it's just this idea that the e
promulgation by the media of the idea
that he was living a lifestyle that is
something that you
I'm elated is truly amazing and it's
truly amazing from the same newspaper by
the way they will talk to routinely
about toxic masculinity autocracy leader
is James Bond sexist what what I mean a
week ago everybody in the media was
saying that Clay Travis was just a bore
for saying on national television that
he believes in two things the First
Amendment in boobs
that was basically Hugh Hefner slogan
and now it's a thirty three hundred word
a little bit in the New York Times so
first endogenous Oakland indogene o is
the way to look good okay if you
actually want to look good if you want
to wear a great-looking suit then you
need to go and check out in dhoti no
they should make custom-made suits just
for you they're making it easy to get a
perfectly tailored suit at an incredible
price it's not something off the rack
you go into Macy's and then you buy a
suit and doesn't that breaks it hangs
off of you instead you're getting a suit
that is tailored to you they take your
measurements they can do it online or
you can go to one of their showrooms and
then they tailor it specifically for you
from scratch and you can make all your
alter your own alterations actually
super cool I've a blue suit that I love
from Indo Chino you can choose the style
of lapel you can choose the kind of
button that you use you can choose the
the seams you can choose the the
interior and the exterior suit and you
can visit a showroom or shop online at
Indo Chino calm and choose your
customizations this week my listeners
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred seventy nine dollars at
Indo Chino calm when they enter Shapiro
at checkout Indo Chino commenters
Shapiro at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price from made-to-measure
premium suit plus the shipping is free
Indo Chino comm promo code Shapiro for
any premium suit just three hundred
seventy nine bucks and free shipping
that's an incredible deal for a
customized suit that probably cost you
$1,000 somewhere else go and check it
out
Indo Chino calm again you go to their
shows actually a fun process go check it
out and use that promo code Shapiro to
get a premium suit for three hundred and
seventy nine bucks it also lets them
know that we sent you okay so back to
Hefner now none of this should be taken
again as the idea that the government
should be banning pornography or the
government should be involved in the
process of doing this the point I'm
making is the D cultural celebration a
vulgar ization of the culture the idea
that this was somehow a broadening of
the public mind that decide who's made
better by this not all exercise of
rights are useful doesn't mean they
should be banned right well what I said
a couple of days ago with regard to for
example kneeling for the
so anthem is that do you have a right to
do that of course you have a right to do
that right here your employer can do
something about it but you have a right
under the First Amendment to not be
punished by government for doing that
every right contains the possibility of
misusing the right we're using it in a
way that's Delmore counterproductive the
First Amendment may contain the right to
publish nude photos of women but to
glorify sin say that this is some sort
of cultural step forward for women is
just ridiculous you could have a
feminist movement without women posing
nude you could mrs. o this is always
been my critique a third way defendant
third wave feminism first wave feminism
said men are acting like pigs they're
borrowing us from the workplace we
should be able to get the jobs that we
want and we should be treated unequal
par with men totally agree with that
right is why my wife's a doctor my mom
worked my dad stayed home but the third
wave feminism basically said men act
like pigs they're gross they treat women
badly you know what that's standard they
have a different standard for us they
want us to be all princesses in the
ivory tower instead of demanding the men
be gentlemen instead get rid of the
ivory tower entirely no rules for anyone
no rules for anyone that does not mean
that I'm in favor of sexual law okay I'm
not again I think the government is
really bad at promulgating this sort of
thing but I am in favor of social
standards that that actually instill
virtue this is why I'm in favor of
people going to church why I'm in favor
of you instilling virtue in your
children you want to have a happier life
live a virtuous life this has become a
very controversial of light and virtue
and Happiness are connected but the
ancients never thought that in fact
Aristotle connected virtue with
happiness the definition of happiness
was living in accordance with virtue
which meant living in accordance with
your purpose unless you think your
purpose on this earth he's to masturbate
as much as humanly possible Hugh Hefner
was not a man driving you torture he was
not a man who's helping to instill
virtue so you know that this this thing
goes on and on and on it says the
Playboy philosophy advocated freedom of
speech and all of its aspects for which
mr. Heflin runs civil liberties Awards
he supported progressive social costs
and lost some sponsors by inviting black
guests to his televised parties of time
and much of the nation still had Jim
Crow laws again Leonard Bernstein
invited black people to his parties to
be no naked women running around there
the idea that it was necessary to to use
sex as a lever in order to break open be
hidebound stupidities of things like Jim
Crow the hive and evil things like to
Carl
I just don't think it's true and you
know who would have agreed with me
people like Martin Luther King who was a
preacher well it's it's I rely I
seriously object to the idea that Hugh
Hefner is somebody who ought to be
emulated or whose life we ought to
celebrate particularly when the central
point of his life was not civil right
stuff the central point of his life was
that he wanted people to be able to get
nudie magazines
that's all 3,300 words on Hugh Hefner
3,000 words on William F Buckley the
founder of the modern conservative
movement just just amazing
again we agree as a society tend to
think it's true in politics too that we
have to swallow the chaff with the wheat
we can't tell what you know if you want
if you want Republicans to or
conservatives to be in the White House
and it has to come through Donald Trump
if you want to win the culture war then
you have to go along with the vulgar is
a ssin of the culture I don't think
that's true I don't think that's true I
think you can fight for good things
without utilizing bad methods and
without embracing bad things I think you
can fight for civil rights without
embracing the idea that that men should
treat women like disposable objects and
when they age out of their beauty and
you just throw them by the side of the
road which is Hugh Hefner's entire
ideology okay so enough about Hugh
Hefner um he is wherever he is today I'm
sad for him that I think that he wasted
his life I'm not gonna make any bones
about that I do think that he wasted his
life because I think the obvious is a
very bright guy could have done a lot
more to to make the world a better place
then promulgate the idea that
promiscuity was virtue and he didn't do
all bad things he did some good things
but when you see somebody who does good
things and does bad once you just wish
they had done a lot more good things and
a lot fewer bad things but I want to
talk a little bit about the next step
for Republicans on Capitol Hill so
Republicans on Capitol Hill have now
moved on from health care so great job
on health care guys
just stellar stellar perch so we now
have we're now well Trump took office in
January it is now the end of September
so they have been off and they've been
in office for nine months there is no
wall they've not revoked Iran do their
if President Trump is working hard on
making sure that daca is rien trying
they've not lowered the budget they've
not cut off funding for Planned
Parenthood and now we're gonna move on
to not passing tax reform that I guess
is the next item on the agenda so
Trump's tax
he's proposing increase increases taxes
apparently on people who are in the
upper tax bracket now what's funny to me
is all the people who are lamenting this
today like Trump didn't say this on the
campaign trail come to this repeatedly
on the campaign trail from said many
times on the campaign trail that he
would increase taxes on the rich who did
a famous Good Morning America feel in
which he said taxes on people like me
they'll go up those texts they'll come
up on people like me I pay I make enough
money right because this is his populist
routine its popular it's kind of done
the reason 10 of them is because people
who are paying the vast majority of
federal taxes in the United States are
the people who make the most money so
when we say we're gonna raise taxes on
the rich but lower it for everyone else
it's kind of hard to lower taxes for
people who are actually getting net
benefits from the government so in the
United States 20 2011 as the
Congressional Budget Office the highest
quintile people who make above 235
thousand dollars a year in the United
States we're paying on average for the
federal government nearly 58 thousand
dollars in taxes per year
the fourth quintile people making above
eighty four thousand dollars a year
they're paying about fourteen thousand
eight hundred dollars to the federal
government the third quintile about 50
thousand bucks a year they were paying
seventy four hundred dollars to the
federal government the second quintile
about 30 grand a year they're paying
thirty two hundred dollars to the
federal government and the lowest
quintile about fifteen thousand five
hundred dollars but lower than thirty
thousand were paying five hundred bucks
to the federal government but that's not
the entire story a lot of these
quintiles receive net benefits back from
the federal government in the form of
disability in the form of food stamps in
the form of welfare in the form of state
sponsored benefits Social Security right
there are there are a lot of benefits
that go back to these various quintiles
when you factor in how much money people
are receiving back from the federal
government in checks in actual transfer
payments what you find out is that the
richest 20% of Americans are paying
virtually all in that federal revenue to
the government nearly all of it
according to Mark Perry of the American
Enterprise Institute the richest 20% of
Americans by income aren't just paying a
share of federal taxes that would be
considered fair there are shouldering
almost 100% of the entire federal tax
burden of transfer payments and all
other non financed government spending
so the idea that you're raising taxes on
the rich because the return' paying
their fair share it's just not factually
true but this is an unpopular thing
right see this is it
Republicans try to pass a tax cut
because they say those for economic
growth will talk about deficits in a
second whenever Republicans say that
they want to pass a tax cut cause it'll
sprechen on the growth people are left
over they just want to cut taxes for
their rich they're a crony rich friend
here's the reality it's very difficult
to cut taxes on people who are not
paying a lot of taxes in the first place
and if you want to spur economic growth
I have never worked for somebody who
only makes $50,000 a year the people you
work for are typically the people in the
top quintile and by the way those people
are not stagnant people go into the top
quintile pull out of the top quintile
yeah idea that there's 1% screwing the
bottom 99% is just not factually true
the number of people who are in the 1%
10 years ago who are now and the 1% is
really low
people move up and down in terms of
income all throughout their life when
you're 20 years old you're probably in
the bottom three quintiles by the time
you're 40 you're probably in the upper
two and you're the same person we're you
a bad person when you were when you're
14 you're a good person when you're 20
so this idea that it's this group of
people who are screwing people to get in
the top 1% for example it's just not
true and if you're on economic growth
you're naturally going to have to cut
taxes for the people who are capable of
investing money so the people who are
actually capable of consumption because
those are the people who are paying the
tax
but nobody's willing to say that cuz
that's unpopular so instead they say
things like we're gonna cut taxes for
the middle class and raise them on the
wealthy right people will actually pay
the vast bulk of taxes so that is what
Trump is saying today which is a
betrayal of his conservative base but
it's not really a betrayal of what he
was saying and this was the problem with
Trump all the way through is that Trump
throughout his campaign was sending
mixed messages
I'll never raise taxes on the rich but
it might raise taxes on the rich guys
and you see this you know even from his
own administration is pretty consistent
message
so you'll see Ted Cruz for example
talking about how we need a tax cut
desperately here's senator Cruz from
Texas making who's that that's good if
you want to see reagan-era
economic growth if you want to see
booming GDP small businesses growing
you've got to have Reagan style tax cuts
real tax cuts not just deficit neutral
adjusting emptying one bucket and
filling another you got to have a real
tax cut on small businesses on job
producers on working families that's how
we unleash the economy okay so you have
Cruz they're making the typical
conservative case now there's Steve
Newton the Treasury secretary
making precisely the opposite case from
the Trump administration as it relates
to the high end you know there's lots of
changes we're getting rid of lots of
deductions we're trying to get rid of
state and local deductions to get the
federal government out of subsidizing it
and yes I can tell you the current plan
for many many people it will not reduce
taxes on the high end okay so there you
have a mixed message from the Republican
Party this is why tax reform will be
difficult because there are going to be
some people who say we're not willing to
allow you to raise taxes on the on the
highest earners and then you're going to
see a bunch of people who say we have to
raise taxes on the highest earners so
there's no guarantee they even get
through tax reform here especially
because they have to do tax reform
through essentially a fifty one-vote
majority they only have 52 votes and
they have to show that the tax reform is
deficit neutral if they want to use
reconciliation right so again it's gonna
be very hard to show that a tax cut is
revenue neutral in general unless you
show some spending offsets unless so
that means you need 60 votes in the
Senate in order to PACs Castro tax
reform so that's not the easiest thing
in the world my talk about deficits in
just a second and what the Republican
and conservative perspective should be
on tax cuts versus deficits it's really
a two-sided argument now I discuss both
sides and you can sort of make up your
own mind on that but first I want to say
thank you to our friends over at
Skillshare so as I was saying if you
want to develop a skill set that is
going to serve you wife long you have to
keep developing it's not the days of
your parents job market where you could
develop one skill set and maintain that
skill set for the rest of your life
working a company for 30 years and
retire with the gold watch that's not
how the job market works right now the
way the job market works is that you
have to be constantly expanding your
skill set and to get better at things
that you don't know anything about and
that is where Skillshare comes in it's
an online learning community with over
17,000 classes in design business and
more you can learn everything from logo
design to social media marketing to
street photography and right now they're
doing unlimited access to all of this
for one low monthly price so you don't
have to pay for class ever again right
now I am taking a skill share class on
social media marketing which is
something we do a lot here at the game
where did you break background and most
of these classes like 45 minutes so
you're learning a new skill in just 45
minutes again they have 17,000 classes
it broadens your capacity to get a
better job and make your life better
Skillshare right now is getting my
listeners a month unlimited access out
solutely free but a Skillshare comm
slash Shapiro to redeem your free month
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro and you
redeem that free month and check it out
I promise you once you've once you
started it really as addictive learning
these things skills sure comm slash
apparel to redeem that free month and
use that promo code Shapiro Skillshare
slash capiro in order to let them know
that we sent you okay so and they hear
this this brings up a second question
with regard to taxes the Republicans
have been split on every day ever since
really the days of Paul Volcker who is
the Treasury secretary or the Fed
Reserve Chairman rather under under
President Reagan and that is do you want
to expand deficit but lower taxes is
that one of your goals now there's some
disco Hawks who say listen the economy
this quarter grew at three point one
percent that's good rate and the reason
it's a good rate and this is this shows
you by the way that doing nothing is
actually really good for the economy as
a general rule there's this idea that
radical change for the economy doesn't
harm the economy one of the reasons the
economy stagnated during President Obama
is recovering at the weakest post-war
recovery in American history the reason
for that is because there was so much
uncertainty about how exactly businesses
we're going to be able to operate
there's been an issue in the regulation
tomorrow was gonna pass a tax increase
businesses have faith the Trump isn't
gonna do anything to dramatically harm
the economy and so they're now spending
money that they were not spending before
and that is creating new jobs they're
investing and they're growing right so
right now it's we need a tax cut listen
we've always need lower taxes as
somebody who pays an enormous amount of
taxes to the government every year I
would personally be hiring more people
if I didn't have to pay those taxes from
by the way is wavering on some of this
you know sighs who wants a twenty
percent corporate tax rate after saving
more than fifteen percent tax rate the
entire election cycle but the real
question is if you are going to pass tax
cuts and you're not gonna focus at all
on entitlement reform you're just going
to continue blowing out the Ducks it in
the short term now the argument that
you're going to expand the pie to the
government increases in in its in its
capacity to bring in tax revenue as the
economy increases so this is the idea of
static versus dynamic modeling static
modeling says that the economy is a
given size if you take a higher tax rate
that means that the government's can
take more of that money that's static
dynamic means the economy doesn't stay
at one size when you give tax cuts that
increases the economy it did so for JFK
it did so for
dragan it did so for george w bush and
that increasing economy is going to mean
that a smaller percentage is still a
bigger absolute number right a smaller
percentage of $100,000 is still a bigger
absolute number than a hundred percent
of $100 that's sort of the logic here
that's true
but in the long run what is really going
to heal the economy of the united states
is not tax cut so much as it is
entitlement reform which is Paul Ryan's
thing and that's the thing that Trump
won't touch that's the thing that Trump
won't touch because that is the third
rail saying to people we're going to
have to restructure of Medicare same to
people we're gonna have to restructure
Social Security that is the truth that
is the truth what is going to bankrupt
this country is not a bush tax cut it is
not a war in Iraq or Afghanistan well
will bankrupt the country is this
looming time bomb of the amount of money
that we owe to people we're gonna be on
Medicare in the very near future on
Social Security in the very near future
the only way those people are going to
make their money is if we either
increase taxes radically borrow
radically which we can't do forever or
inflate the dollar that's really the
methane or we can cut benefit which we
shouldn't do now but we should structure
it so that there is a trailing benefit
that's what we should do because I've
never been missing my Social Security
money entitlement reform would be better
for the future of the country than a tax
cut tax cuts were more politically
profitable so with the Republican
majority what I would suggest is that
Republicans start pushing both the
Republicans start pushing both and that
entitlement reform is the more important
of the two do the Republicans have the
guts to do that I doubt it they couldn't
even pass tax reform I mean I mean they
can't then impacts health health care
reform which they've been campaigning on
for seven years but that's the real
looming time bomb in all of this so
what's interesting about this is with
all these divisions inside the
Republican Party some leadership would
be really great right now you know
presidents from saying here's what I
want here's why we want to make the case
to the American people
take that bully pulpit that he's got and
go and bully a little bit rank stop
talking by the NFL so much and go out
and start talking about here's my plan
here's why it's gonna do the Ronald
Reagan thing take out a chart and show
people how this works but that's not
what Trump is doing that's not what
Trump is doing and that's a problem I
want to talk about that problem in how
Republicans are reacting to that problem
I also want to talk about some more of
the NFL fallout but for all of that
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire calm right now and subscribe $9.99
a month gets you a subscription to daily
wire
and then can watch the rest of the show
live on video you can always listen live
for free and iTunes of soundcloud but if
you want to see the show it's a visual
show then go over to daily where you can
see the rest of the show live it's the
Andrew Clayton's show live at starting
in about an hour here you're gonna see
Michael Mosley's show live which is
starting in about three hours here all
of these are great shows and you should
check them out plus gets been part of my
mailbag so you want all your life
questions answered you want your life
made better then on Friday we will do
the mailbag but you don't get your
questions answered unless you give us
money so you're gonna have to go over
and subscribe we are capitalists we are
not communists therefore you have to go
over and subscribe ninety-nine and $9.99
a month you're on the annual
subscription that's ninety nine dollars
a year and you get our world-famous
leftist here's how to call the tumbler
you'll enjoy is the greatest holder of
liquid that ever you have seen and
you'll treasure it forever until you die
and put your ashes in it and put it on
the mantle and then you'll just be
encapsulated in there you don't have to
do that part but it's a nice copy so go
check that 99 bucks for the annual
subscription or you want to listen later
please subscribe over at YouTube or
iTunes or SoundCloud you can do all that
for free and leave us a review and would
that always helps us we always
appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so with the Republican Party's so split
this is the time where presidential
leadership is really necessary Barack
Obama was good at this
George W Bush is go to this Trump
unfortunately gets easily distracted if
you've ever seen the movie up Trump is
basically the dog right it's just
there's a squirrel and it runs by and
then Trump goes well and then you just
run down this world and this is not a
useful quality when you actually mean
single-minded focus to wrangle the herd
of cats but you need the dog to wrangle
the cats you don't need the dog to chase
the squirrel that's what I'm trying to
tell you here and right now the dog is
not wrangling the cats in the in the
Senate so Trump is spending his time
still moaning about why health care
didn't pass and he's he's saying things
that are actually not true about health
care he's saying that health care reform
didn't pass because stad Cochran the
senator from Mississippi was in the
hospital no that wouldn't made any
difference at all they didn't have the
votes for it but Trump keeps saying this
kind of stuff right here's from talking
about health care I also want to provide
a brief update on health care we have
the votes on Graham Cassidy okay you
said that we but Eden so there is that
um and then you have Paul Ryan and
what's weird is that you can have the
situation where Trump is really
necessary to push this thing forward and
he's not doing what he needs to do but
everybody is afraid enough of crossing
him that they're just going to continue
paying him homage which doesn't create
an incentive for him to actually do the
right thing so Paul Ryan who I mean I've
never seen a person become as
uncomfortable in his own skin as Paul
Ryan over the last year there's
something desperately funny about
watching videos of Paul Ryan trying to
push policy into the absolute void that
is our current political discussion like
in the middle of the NFL debate earlier
this week Paul Ryan just tweeted out a
video of himself talking about tax
reform and how he's pushing for a better
way and it was like it really was like
Kevin Bacon in Animal House and
everybody behind him is screaming and
beating each other with clubs and he's
going everyone stay calm
it's all fine everything is good here so
he's on with Sean Hannity last night and
Sean obviously is a huge Trump in and
here's Paul Ryan bending the knee to to
president Truong
what's your relationship with it's very
good it's a very opposite edge we have a
great relationship but we happy with
this presidents be very happy but you
don't have that in the house
representatives
have caucuses every week you don't hear
that kind of talk from them from the
house representative I have not heard it
from House members so you don't hear
that from House members look I think the
president is giving us the kind of
leadership we need to get this country
back on the right track he's so happy so
yeah all right super happy with the
leadership montañés
but he knows that if he crosses
President Trump then from start slapping
Ryan instead of slapping McConnell any
connection really funny it's turned into
basically a Three Stooges routine where
Trump knocks Ryan on the head and Ryan
pokes takes his fingers and pokes
McDonald in the eyes and then that's
basically why nothing's getting done
because we're all laughing in slapstick
here's Ryan bashing McConnell yesterday
on Sean's show of course I'd like to see
them do majority votes on these thirty
ever ask McConnell we've talked about a
lot I don't think that they don't
devotes therefore that's just this flat
simple answer so what do I do is that
house we don't even get the votes to get
that dug anyway there's many of in
charge of the rules is the Manoa today I
don't think there's enough Republicans
to vote for that because they worry that
when liberals take over government
liberals will ran through was a legend
but they're okay so and then he pulls
out a chart actually and he shows a
chart of how many bills the house has
passed and how many bills the Senate has
passed and of course the Senate passed
nothing so he's slapping McConnell for
that and basically it's it's signal to
trunk please don't slap me I'm your
friend mr. Trump please leave me alone
the president's fear is not being used
in the proper way
okay the fear of the presidency is not
being used in the proper way you got a
wheel you got a deal
this was the stuff Tony said he was good
at remember Trump promised this was all
going to be easy he said it over and
over and the guarantee was gonna be easy
as that who's a great businessman who
was awesome at making deals right this
was his shtick his entire stick was it's
gonna be so easy it's gonna make your
head swim
we're gonna win we're gonna win we're
never gonna stop winning we're just
gonna win forever right why because all
these people can't make deals I'm a deal
maker look at me I'm a deals hon boobie
you know is it it's but that's not
what's happening and instead it's it's
funny because where he should be herding
cats instead it's just him running after
the latest squirrel and the Republicans
using that as an excuse to bolt and look
no no some of this isn't Trump's fault
like it's not Trump's fault but the
Senate can't get together but it is a
missed opportunity and that's fronts
fault so South Trump's fault the McCain
and Susan Collins and Rand Paul can't
get on the same page of course they
get on the same page but it certainly
doesn't help when the President of the
United States his final health care push
is the Colin Kaepernick's a jerk right
his last health care push if you recall
a few months ago his final health care
push there was Jeff Sessions is a jerk
his own attorney general so like if he
would focus a little bit that would be
really really helpful and I don't see an
incentive for him to focus so long as
Republicans keep saying how great he is
and and Trump threatens them that if
they don't work with him he still walk
across the street to his good friends
Nancy and Chuck it's it here's the thing
I'm not sure that the fear of Trump is
particularly justified what I mean by
this is that people are not vote and
like people as I said yesterday if you
slap Trump openly then people get mad at
you right if you say is politician that
I think Trump's doing a crappy job then
people get angry at you in the
Republican Party because they think
you're being disloyal to a guy they all
voted for him that much is true and
that's why I don't think that you know
it's incumbent on Paul Ryan I think from
suing the crappy job but I think that
when he's asked about it he should say
no I think President Trump you know has
the right principles in mind but I would
love to see him really push that to the
American public more right trying to
prompt him in the right direction that
he can do and that's not being done the
reason that I think that can be done is
because you actually saw that happen in
Alabama right Trump actually endorsed
the candidate lost and the tea party
people who have been really driving this
movement since 2010 pushed Roy Moore
instead and they went right over Trump's
head and Roy Moore wasn't seen as an
enemy of Trump so long as he said that
he liked Trump everything was fine so I
think so long as you say that you don't
hate Trump then you can actually make
the case for conservative principles I'm
not sure that the fear of Trump is
justified that if Trump brings the
hammer to you you're inherently finished
I think you have to do one very specific
thing that it's going to Trump
personally and then people get mad at
you but if you say you think Trump needs
to do a better job I don't think that
people are going to get particularly
happy with you plus the idea that Trump
is is somebody who is going to do
anything just fulminating on Twitter is
I think a little bit exaggerated the
deep truth about Trump is that Trump
doesn't actually like getting into
conflict where he's personally
responsible it's kind of weird like
Trump and Trump likes to talk the
language of conflict but he doesn't like
to fire people he doesn't like to openly
break with people he likes to keep his
options open much like Hugh Hefner he
likes to keep his options open
and so here
for example you know Tom Price is
helping Human Services Secretary he
can't be happy that um price Tom price
was taking government jets different
places and spent a lot of money didn't
do much on the healthcare vote and here
was Trump being asked about Tom price
yesterday and here is Trump's response
personally I'm not happy about it I have
not
I am not happy about it and I let him
know
and that's what Trump said is you recall
about Jeff Sessions and he says it's
about a lot of his people that he's not
happy about them but then he doesn't
really fire them
he doesn't really fire them the only
person that he's legitimately fired in
his administration was James Comey he
tried to pawn that off on Brad Rosen
state rights today so he actually
doesn't like follow up firing people so
you know I think that you can push Trump
without him spewing all over you except
maybe a little bit on Twitter and I
think the Republicans should prod him in
the right direction if they don't and
it's just gonna be squirrel chasing from
here for the rest of the presidency okay
so now on to the NFL fallout meanwhile
well I talked about the dysfunction on
the right this function on the left is
just increasing at an equal or greater
pace whatever the the poop storm that is
that is begun on the right it is twice
that on the left the language that is
being used the polarizing language that
really alienates Americans on these
issues being used by the left being
embraced by Democrats is truly
astonishing so Spike Lee who is
obviously somebody who is considered by
the leftist civil rights hero and civil
rights leader the filmmaker he is using
a sort of polarizing language that is
not gonna benefit Democrats it really
doubles down on the identity politics
the Democrats have embraced it's not
gonna be good for Democrats and it's not
good for the country they're taking the
opportunity of they don't like Trump to
go as radical as they possibly can which
i think is so stupid I mean if Trump
makes mistake why don't you just call
him on the mistake is what I've been
saying to people on the left forever I
don't get it if you think Trump's making
mistake why don't you just say here's
the mistake you're making and here's why
it's bad instead of it's the end of the
world the sky is falling we're all gonna
die he's a racist the cake cake cake
cake cake came will be outside my house
in the morning like you're not doing
anyone any favors by always turning that
knob to love and hear Spike Lee turning
the knob cast 11 if you're turning the
knob off the off the stereo just go on
now it's rolling around on the floor
somewhere you're Spike Lee it's like
like the owners or the the plantation
owners and the guys playing a league you
know they're on the plantation you can't
say anything and so the thing is really
escalated because he compares the NFL
owners to members of a plan that
plantation owners hey those guys make
millions of dollars a year and they are
paid to play a sport it is not like a
plantation and it's deeply insulting to
people who lived in
Lavery and some who still from slavery
you suggest that people in the NFL are
like plantation owners every business if
you had a belt decided tomorrow and they
actually wanted to make the players
stand up or they would suspend them or
find them maybe well within their rights
to do that so I think they ought to do
that
at this point I don't think they ought
to do that but is that something that
the NFL could do and has the right to DX
would that make them plantation owners
absolutely not any more than any
business has rules I said this even
about chains tomorrow at Google I think
Google was wrong to fire James d'amour
for for putting out a memo that seemed
to me largely well reason did they have
the right to do it of course they had
the right to do it didn't make them
plantation owners no I mean he had a job
for which he was being paid they didn't
like it was a fireman like that was bad
that was wrong but that's not the
equivalent of living on a plantation
Steph Curry is doing some of his
polarizing language too
so he was talking about the Sports
Illustrated cover we mentioned yesterday
Sports Illustrated is trying to take the
tactic of the kneeling isn't about the
anthem it's not about the flag and
signing about police brutality it's
about opposition trunks with dated is
they alighted Colin Kaepernick from
their cover and some people on the left
are understandably angry about this they
say Kaepernick started this movement why
isn't he on the cover with the rest of
us standing up to police brutality what
they don't understand is the more you
tie yourself to Colin Kaepernick that's
what he's an anchor on your movement if
you want to tie your leg to Colin
Kaepernick's like you are going down and
those waves will follow you immediately
Steph Curry doesn't seem to really get
that here he is Sports Illustrated
you're right in the middle but
kaepernick how do you feel about that I
was terrible
this kind of capitalize
[Music]
the median or
the real people that understand the
exact
who's really been active in local
truly making a difference Kaepernick is
super unpopular with the American people
the American people don't like
Kaepernick's protests they don't want
people fired but they don't like it and
the more the left eye's itself to
Kaepernick this is where it Trump's
little little routine has worked very
well actually is that the left instead
of saying we have the right to standards
kneel as we see fit they said we like
Colin Kaepernick he's a hero again that
overreach is not smart politics Michelle
Obama engaged in some very not smart
identity politics yesterday here she is
saying that any woman who voted against
Hillary Clinton voted against women
generally she told this audience at this
conference in Boston there's just one
piece of it quote any woman who voted
against Hillary Clinton voted against
their own voice what does it mean for us
as women that we look at these two
candidates as women and many of us said
that guy he's better for me
his voice is more true to me well to me
that just says you don't like your voice
you like the thing women don't like
their own voice if they didn't vote for
Hillary Clinton maybe they just didn't
like Hillary Clinton's voice because
she's a crazy old bat like maybe many
people just didn't like Hillary Clinton
because she's really off-putting as a
candidate and now off-putting as a human
being maybe that's why the left has to
engage in this identity politics you
really think you're gonna win back the
white women who voted majority for Trump
by saying that they didn't understand
what it was like to be a woman and so
they didn't vote for Hillary Clinton
this is that really the direction you
wanted to left us is that really the
picture on me so I say there's
dysfunction on the left this is the
dysfunction on the left it is function
on the right they can't get their act
together they don't have any
centralizing principle and so they're
fragmenting in every possible direction
and unable to get anything done the
fragmentation on the left is less a
fragmentation than a movement toward a
more unpopular politics that makes the
country worse in the nature of identity
politics I'm frankly I'm shocked that
Michelle Obama came out and said that
because I think it's you're smarter than
that that's just dumb politics but for
her to do that it just demonstrates how
far down the rabbit hole
the Democrats are with regard to this
identity politics okay time for some
things I like and then we'll do some
things that I hate so things that I like
so I was a University of Utah last night
with a fantastic event
packed house enthusiastic audience it
was really quite wonderful there are
protesters outside
some people got violent three people
were arrested watch steven crowder show
tonight
okay steven crowder has a show tonight
apparently went undercover not gay
Jerrod went undercover is producer went
undercover with antifa
and the film is truly amazing so we'll
play click Submit tomorrow on the show
but if you don't get a chance watch
Crowder show tonight Crowder and in his
great journalistic work you should go
check it out tonight and aloud with
Crowder go check it out it's really
really amazing stuff I've seen some of
the footage it's truly amazing so we're
gonna do because we're new top I'm gonna
do Mormon related things that I like and
things that I hate so things that I like
Mormon related so there's a movie that
came out in 2003 didn't get a lot of
play but it's actually quite at the
movies called Saints and soldiers found
World War two it's a world war two movie
in which it's basically a band of
American soldiers trying to make it out
from behind enemy lines in I think it's
in Belgium and and back across to
American lines and the main character is
a guy who carries around the Book of
Mormon with him and it's it's actually
quite a moving film sort of about the
role of religion in in viewing virtue
and the role of heroism and and also the
role of redemption in you've made
mistakes you've done things that are
wrong and what can you do to redeem
yourself the movie has Saints in
soldiers who's a little bit of the
preview Alan Moore's reported American
combat
persecuted by their german cancer near
the Belgian town of mama D an unknown
number of Germans are making a push
towards in town for their strippers
nursery behind enemy lines has pushed
through all of them here trapped deep
behind enemy lines okay so the movies
actually quite good and you should check
it out of town Amazon Prime so if you're
a Prime member then you can watch that
for free I don't have done it flicks but
it is well worth watching it again I
like movies that take seriously the
contentions of religion even if you
don't believe in all the particular
doctrines of a particular faith like
take religion seriously one of my pet
peeves about a lot of atheists is they
do this routine where they'll say things
like if you're a religious person how do
you you know do religious people even
know like how can you how could there be
a god if bad things happen in the world
have you even thought of that
hmm and say yes we've thought of that
yes we yes every religious thinker in
history has taken on this question like
do some basic research like please for
the love of Pete if you're gonna rip on
religion like do some research okay time
for some things I hate we'll do a Mormon
related things I hate okay so the thing
that I hate today is the musical The
Book of Mormon the Book of Mormon is
it's very clever I mean I think that
it's it's got stuff that's funny it's
super vulgar which makes sense does the
guys who wrote South Park wrote the Book
of Mormon it is it is clever the thing
that I hate about it is the scorn that
it shows for for Mormonism as a faith by
mocking its central beliefs let's be
straight about religion in general
organized religion in general most
religions make miraculous claims now I
think some of those miraculous claims
are more ludicrous than others but
virtually every major religion makes
claims about miracles and at a certain
point you're gonna have to take a leap
of faith mocking those leaps of faith to
me is just sneering at is sneering at
somebody else without recognizing your
own vulnerability on these issues
now there's also something to me it's a
little bit off-putting about targeting
Mormons who are legitimately like the
nicest people in America I said last
night at the beginning of my speech that
this is the only state in the Union
where I'm the least clean-cut guy in the
state I mean Mormons as
the Mormons that I know the Mormons that
in general that I know are the nicest
cleanest cut people with wonderful
families and ripping on the Mormons is
so it's like hitting a puppy like really
the Mormons that those are the people
that you're gonna rip up if you really
had any guts a night Trey stone and Matt
Parker do have you have got because
they'd actually tried to go after like
drawing cartoons of Muhammad on South
Park but let's just put it this way
welcome a Mormon came out and the people
in the Mormon Church were accurate they
said they were actually happy about it
because you gave them an opportunity to
actually hand out more copies in the
Book of Mormon and recruit right if
they've done if they've done the book of
Mohammed okay every theater in the
United States would now be on fire okay
there would be legitimate Isis terrorist
attacks on theaters in the United States
they put out the book of mom so it seems
like it's an easy target here's one of
the songs from the from the show that is
supposed to demonstrate sort of the
naivete of Mormons by the way it's when
I say that this week's people here's
what I mean I get off the plane
yesterday and I come down into the
baggage claim area and there's a huge
crowd of people they're not waiting for
me of course they're they're waiting for
people are coming who are coming back
from Mission a huge crowd of people
families with signs say people who've
gone abroad trying to help people and
these people like these kids who are out
helping people you know how many 17 18
year old kids do you know we're spending
a couple of years of their life going
out and helping random people or in dire
poverty and they're being celebrated by
their families these beautiful families
who are saying to them congratulations
on doing something good for the world
it's the opposite you have her
congratulations and doing something good
for the world these are the people who
you're gonna mock these are the people
who are gonna say are the problem so
here's here's the number from the Book
of Mormon again doing the very easy
thing of mocking somebody's ludicrous
religious beliefs which again I can do
the same thing about scientific
materialism scientific materialism is
based on premises that cannot pop hold
he central contentions of scientific
materialism under scientific materialism
you cannot argue for truth you cannot
argue for reason you cannot argue argue
through logic you can't give an argument
scientific method by the tenants of
scientific materialism if I can mock to
death this stuff I don't do that because
I think that it's worth taking seriously
other people's claimed anyway here is
here's a number from the Book of Mormon
[Applause]
[Music]
ever since I was a child I tried to be
the best so what happened my family and
friends all said I was blessed so what
happened you're supposed to be all so
exciting
to be teaching a Christ's cross the sea
but I allowed my faith to be shaken Oh
what's the matter with me I've always
along to help the needy to do the things
I never dared this was the time for me
to step up so then why was I so scared a
warlord who shoots people in the face
what's so scary about that I must trust
that my Lord is mightier and always has
my back
now I must be completely devout I can't
have even once
I believe
the Lord got read in the universe I
daddy sent His only Son to die
for my sins
[Music]
okay so this is the part that I that I
hate about this is the idea so that last
lyric there again is it funny of course
it's easy to make fun of people's
religious beliefs super super easy but
when he says things like I believe that
the word God created the universe I
believe that Jesus died for my sins I
believe that the the ancient Jews sailed
on boats to America and then the
audience laughs it is that all of these
beliefs are equally stupid and all of
these beliefs are equally ignorant and
what this guy is doing is just doing
because he's in naive form and that's
the idea is that religious people are
naive fools who believe they can make
the world a better place with their
belief in this giant spaghetti monster
in the sky it is super dismissive of
what religious people have done what
religious people have built and what
religious people actually believe talk
to a religious person sometime if you
think that religious people have never
thought about the ridiculousness and
some of the things that we believe and
the leaps of faith that we have to make
you've never talked to a religious
person and we're not just all fools who
go around and thinking for ourselves
well you know every word of the Bible is
not only literally true but I don't see
why anyone can't believe it okay if you
don't doubt you're not a religious
person that's what faith means faith
means not only do you have doubts but
that you live with the doubts and you
wrestle with the doubts every day this
is why I love to say that the word
Israel right I'm a member of the nation
of Israel you know I'm Neeson I write
that word in the Bible means struggles
with God and overcomes that's what it
means
that's what it means to be a religious
person and it seems to me that if you're
gonna do a musical about religious
people it should look a lot more like
movie silence from Martin Scorsese and a
lot less like like the Book of Mormon
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow and
I will be back from our beautiful
studios in Los Angeles and look forward
to seeing you then I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]